hello and welcome to this video playing
morning star from the US morning star of
this is a good line from like hopefully
it doesn't it doesn't catch on with too
many people Queen a for the IDS to
enforce black ensure recapturing with
the peace and not with a pawn on d5 it's
not a big deal but yeah that's not a bad
thing to achieve for white so here d3
Bishop h6 is an idea oh so what are you
saying there that my queen on age six
doesn't really need me much that's true
actually I don't have many squares to go
turn okay night g5 I can go 95 actually
[Music]
eat pho why not h5 was that so bad hmm
remarkable ok so I get the Queen I keep
the Queen ok d 4 D 3 mm I have a
preference for d4 here somehow I know
that is hanging but it doesn't doesn't
really look ok Bishop h6 now I felt that
taking it was a temple did know mr.
Morningstar black realize when I was a
short game well okay i can post it
because of the opening is may be
interesting for some people the bit of a
too short game let's click on analysis
yeah this is a very decent setup for
black and queen a4 i think is however
nice try i'm not saying it gives
widen advantage I'm not doing that but i
think it's um it's interesting the
positions after taking this kind of
thing is just very equal and this at
least give some additional flavor to the
game let's say while it tends to take
and make black we capture with the peas
as it happened here this is nothing
nothing much but it is a bit more
non-symmetrical so this is felt very
normal he went here and maybe clean edge
for isn't all that great i don't know
can also go we five him yet this 95 yeah
of course here just h5 Ian it's not a
big problem i know i can just do this
cover everything I mean maybe I'm a
little bit better because there was a
little point and getting into this week
structure on the King side but yeah this
is great of course yeah and now be three
as indicated by the comp also pretty
sensible but this is not bad if he takes
I get get tempe rookie one or I was
thinking this also may be happy v three
seems stronger but ok this is now is
fantastic for white I'm getting all the
play on the dark squares and while you
can certainly improve on that move it's
not not easy for black this is indicated
by the computer and g4 already looks
very strong not sure I would have played
that I think I'm I would have been
tempted by this move as well just please
play with g4s of course is very direct
yeah it's it will be very tough for
black to them ok guys thanks for
watching